c'est en tout cas c'est fou c'est un
smartphone avec un clavier lentement
comme ça une fois qu'il est ouvert il
est comme ça ça rappelle un peu les
smartphone de motorola si vous voulez
vraiment un clavier physique et d'un
moulage et avec des trucs sont quand
même à cette éminente on peut vraiment
voulu l'utiliser pour bosser la boîte
qui fait ça s'appelle planète le modèle
c'est l'astrance live alors je sais pas
s'il ya vraiment un marché parce que
c'est quand même très énorme c'est
massif vous avez des bords énorme mais
on peut l'ouvrir alors c'est un peu
galère et je vis mal à le faire mais bon
on craque et ouvert il est comme ça ça
c'est rigolo je sais pas ça pourrait
vous intéresser à d'ailleurs vu que moi
tout de suite en commentaire